we got new merch some new colorways uh
in the be good to yourself collection
we've got hoodies in Plum and Moss we've
also got t-shirts in lilac moss and Blue
Mist
hope you enjoy those those are good
colors
get that hitter and more at
theovinstore.com I want to let you know
that we have some new tour dates to
announce
January 11th and 12th in Grand Junction
Colorado we've added a new show there
January 13th Pueblo Pueblo Colorado
January 14th Denver we have two shows
there January 15th down in Fort Collins
Colorado we are excited to be at the
fort
and March 1st 3rd and 4th in Boston
Massachusetts and March 2nd in Medford
Massachusetts those are all available at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r and that will be the return of
the Rat tour
today's guest
um is a uh connector
he's a man that
that that Bridges space between two
things he's a bridge he's a you know he
might be a drawbridge at times I don't
know
we're going to learn just how he
connects people
um and we're going to talk about just
his journey in journalism
um you may know him from all gas no
breaks uh from French Quarter
confessions
um or from his own channel five today's
guest is Andrew Callahan
[Music]
wrong
let us pop some deodorant today I
haven't yeah I just got back into
putting deodorant on yeah I actually
didn't wear it for like a year but then
like just the past couple months I don't
know if my diet changed but like the bo
is back really so I actually just gave
myself a hand soap like uh armpit bath
in your in the podcast bathroom oh wow I
don't know how close we're gonna be
sitting so I was like damn I don't want
you to be holding your tongue about my
armpit odor the whole time yeah you know
because that might send the interview in
a different direction subconsciously
yeah that's a good point man I I hadn't
thought about that I think uh there are
people you get around them and when they
got that
that odor sometimes it repels you
sometimes I notice it
it's almost like a well it feels a
little bit like uh not welcoming but
there's a human yeah space in there
that's kind of okay like you're fallible
like you smell like I do yeah yeah yeah
like okay I'ma ride this guy you know
I'll give this guy a chance yeah sounds
like [ __ ] yeah
we are couples couple stench bunnies
I'll ride with this homie right here dog
um but I just you know I took a couple
years off too and just the other day I
put it on yeah and I was like you know I
think there's something
it was a casual and it was like mint and
something else it was one of those more
like uh one somebody made in the woods
or made at their house yeah and I was
like I can I like this a little organic
style yeah not like a typical ax
chocolate or like Old Spice Swagger or
any of those like super heavy chemical
ones yeah that's the ones that started
getting scary yeah I used to collect all
that [ __ ] all the acts flavors you did
when I was a kid dude they had a wife
you collected I think I was a victim of
the ax marketing like they had the ax
chocolate commercial was like he walks
out of the house and all the ladies are
just like all over him and I was like
that's gonna be me dude I was in seventh
grade I was like gotta keeps stacking up
ax deodorant flavors and see which one
works for me yeah boy you get them axes
boy you get as much [ __ ] deodorant as
you can
yeah I remember something like that dude
being young and this they had this fell
in our uh class named Michael and people
used to beat him up a lot and his dad
could fix computers or whatever and
where I was from if somebody could fix
computers it was almost like they worked
for Satan you know like yeah people
didn't want that you know can you fix a
[ __ ] truck boy you know what I'm
saying like get out of here with your
damn wires you know and uh and he I
think felt like
deodorant would give him power and I
remember he would put it on his whole
body
really up and down his Limbs and
everything yeah
and it really didn't help him much it
made him you know it made him enjoyable
to be around kind of but I don't think
it helped him in like the emotional
sense that he was looking for for like a
parent you know yeah because you would
put like and he would put that Old Spice
to Splash stuff on just all over his
entire body yeah like on the front of
his hands yeah yeah make a face too I'm
not sure how much he did on that young
skin it would probably really burn him
I'm sure he smelled great oh dude he was
but I think what he was looking for he's
like if I get enough maybe this positive
smell maybe my father will love me so
you said that like a computer programmer
is like the least honorable profession
where you grew up in Louisiana at the
time it was what do you think at that
time was like the most respectable line
of work
[Music]
um
probably Tire Care yeah fixing them
patching them up yeah yeah you could
roll in there and roll out in about 12
13 minutes you know yeah is this before
a Discount Tire kind of like took the
mom and pop Tire spots out of business
yeah back in the good old days yeah back
when you rolled in there and a guy could
he would a guy would he wouldn't even
have to he'd smell around the tire yeah
no it was up I love tire shops oh dude
they were so good that one of the guys
try to make love to my mother for a
while and I think that also made me
think oh these guys are heroes yeah why
because it was somebody that cared about
my mom I guess you know it was like oh
man these guys they could change the
tire on your life you know yeah they're
heroic for sure about being like you
know someone that loves you but um
anyway man Andrew Callan thanks for
being here bro uh thanks man so some
audience might not know you right you
were certainly like
you are a wizard in your own and in a
very huge world of Journalism but in
your own world like take me through a
little bit of where you started out so
Andrew's kind of like this I don't know
I'm labeled like this Hunter S Thompson
kind of like this you know this like uh
you're a journalist that's safe
statement yeah you told me one time when
I met you you said I followed the vibe
or the heat I follow where the Energy's
at yeah definitely yeah and so you're
like a Seeker kind of yeah
um
where do you where do you kind of start
out I first saw you on French Quarter
confessions because I'm from Louisiana
that was my first video project I was at
doorman on Bourbon Street in the corner
and I would get off work and like
interview drunk people for late night
confessionals like when they're out
partying on Bourbon and Royal and any
surrounding streets sometimes on
Frenchmen sometimes we got a little
crazy but I mean I started uh I read
from my high school newspaper and then
like I had this cool ass High School
teacher I didn't really like school too
much but I had a journalism class and
this teacher Calvin would let me like
leave school for the whole day and I
would come back at the end of the day
like before the bell rang at like 3 25
and he said if you had a story of of a
cool person that you talked to or
someone interesting out there I'd give
you School Credit so I was able to just
roam Seattle like
free roam throughout the day and I would
come back with like stories about
Juggalos that I would meet downtown yeah
you know like how to buy some [ __ ] off
the Silk Road I would go to the Occupy
Movement Tent City and interview people
there and just come back and just like
write a write a little article we're
right up and I got school credit and
then he helped me that kind of
experience like propelled me to go to
college in Louisiana on a full
scholarship to elliola oh wow so they
gave you could that's where you went
down there Loyola yeah Wolfpack yeah you
know about the wolf pack dude I went to
Loyola for one semester no he didn't
yeah dude you live in Beaver Hall in the
dorms uh no I try to do cocaine with a
girl one time and I couldn't get an
erection and I and I I've always felt
horrible about that that one experience
is the reason you dropped out of college
uh it made me I think leave
because it was a small campus I didn't
want to see her oh that's a small campus
you know you see every student every day
at Loyola yes yeah yeah there's no like
there's no place to hide over there yeah
and if you go to the boot or the palms
or like snake and Jake's or one of those
like college bars you really see the
same people every day yeah and somebody
usually I feel like there's a sex crime
there every night like it almost should
be like sex crime Sunday you know it
should be like a thing for sure yeah
like a game of Clue they kind of like
give you like a little check off sheet
yeah those particular bars like on the
corner of like Broadway and zimple all
right [ __ ] nightmare yeah people are
peeing and drinking at the same time
like it's a big and fighting and making
out and grinding which I didn't really
know continued into adulthood I thought
grinding was like a middle school
sort of like uh you know like it's like
but at the boot like right now there's
someone at the boot grinding with a
stranger with their eyes closed just
[ __ ] like the song Candy Shop is
playing and they're just like yeah
straight up vibing it out making out why
is that why is there something about and
that's how I think I look that is that
dirty Louisiana thing where it's like
let's just get together let our [ __ ]
oysters touch you know there's something
about that I mean I didn't know because
I did some grinding my freshman year at
loyal you know because everyone else is
grinding and I didn't know at that time
but that would be the last time I'd ever
grind yeah you know what I mean I
wouldn't have believed you if you told
me at that time yeah but then I was in
the boot and I was like this is [ __ ]
weird and it never happened again
I wonder if there'd be like a good
grinding Championship that would see
something that would be something I
could see going to interview I think
Jamaica would win have you seen the
dagger dancing uh-uh they're like
jumping up and down let me try to like
like dramatic air humping like you have
to look it up I'll send you some videos
it sounds like some of the Maasai
warrior stuff is it like that like when
those got like they do a lot of that
it's just like that oh wow that's
interesting yeah
um okay so you you came through French
Quarter confessions that's where a lot
of people I think that's where I first
started about you from being from
Louisiana yeah and um did you miss that
do you miss that Louisiana Energy kind
of so much man I think about it all the
time like like when I dream it's like
they all take place in the streets of
like New Orleans like it's like my
mental map you know what I'm talking
about it's a special place once once you
connect to it it like never leaves you
yeah you know but it's also hard to find
work out there like it's hard to build a
career in media out there yeah I think
it's really really hard yeah like
there's like the news channels and then
there's like crime yeah or you play for
the Saints I feel like there's not a lot
of of yeah Avenues to to build a name
for yourself for sure I mean the one
time I tried to get involved in like
local uh like local TV stations in
Louisiana I just I decided an NDA and
they're like we're not going to tell you
what your assignment is but just sign
this and we're going to get you on TV
and I'm like all right cool so I sign it
and they send me in like a sprinter van
to Covington Louisiana yeah and they're
like you see this woman her house just
burnt down
she doesn't know this yet but her two
dogs are dead inside the house you gotta
go walk in that house with her
and write about it I was like this is
the worst job ever it was like maybe
gender reveal I'm a bit not like that
yeah it was the saddest thing I've ever
seen yeah and so I was like I don't want
to do this but after court of
confessions like I would uh hitchhike
around the US a lot like by myself I'm
like oh you did so you got so after that
you then you made it into hitchhiking
yeah pretty much like right around there
too so I would hitchhike from like
Seattle to New Orleans and back and just
interview like Outlaws runaways
deadbeats like crazy Motel creatures in
like Nevada you know the real reptilians
oh yeah man look I've done a lot of
picking up hitchhikers over my day and
people that I mean I remember the worst
one I ever had was a guy not the worst
really the best also this guy uh what
did he say oh he goes you want a cold
beer and I'm like there's no [ __ ] way
this dude there's a cold beer on him
pulled a cold beer out of his jacket man
like I don't know if you've been cooling
with his heart or just whatever he had
you know and he pulled a cold beer out
of his jacket and I was like oh this
dude is a real some type of like uh
future baby or some type of wizard or
something and then uh he told me a story
one time he got picked up by a guy one
time
and it was in a hot the guy ended up
being in a high speed chase from the
police right so next you know this
hitchhiker's in a high-speed chase right
yeah and so he's like he asked the guys
like why'd you pick me up and he goes
because I don't want to die alone
yeah
one second
yeah gotta get some phlegm out real
quick yeah get it out man
we'll sell it actually
okay so you get into the hitchhiking
take me on some of your hitchhiking
Journey right there I mean just
just everything was so ridiculous like
every ride was like crazier than the
last you know what I mean like there's
always that one story that I tell about
like
tiny like Honduran dude picking me up in
Crowley Louisiana and like taking me to
like a refurbished barn house that had
like 12 confessional booths and I didn't
know that it was like a porn viewing
have you been to a place like this was
it like a uh people kind of a gay meet
up or just okay or straight I think it's
a place where truckers pull over to like
have a private pornography viewing
experience they have like a bottle of
lotion and like they have three channels
they have like the gay channel regular
channel then like the fetish Channel or
whatever so I'm thinking I picked this
dude up he has like a [ __ ] up car and
uh he takes me to the place to view it
tries to you know see what was up and I
was like nah
and then he was like oh why were you at
that truck stop and I guess where he
picked me up was like a known
kind of a notorious Bae for notorious
notorious gay prostitute truck stop
so he thought that I was a I wonder why
he didn't say anything for an hour in
the car but he didn't want to get like
get a solicitation charge so he didn't
say much because he kind of figured I'd
let it out he wanted he was asking me
weird questions like do you like porn do
you like movies and I was like this guy
right yeah do you like if you ever yeah
what kind of condiments do you like yeah
just like strange [ __ ] like that super
super weird yeah but I wrote a book
about the hitchhiking like a Zine thing
yeah yeah and like people liked it I
probably sold a couple hundred copies
like that was good but then I realized
like nobody really reads dude
yeah reading is a tough thing for people
do you even find for yourself that it's
hard to read these days I'd prefer to
listen to a podcast or an audiobook you
know but it is like a calming like uh
thing to do reading yeah I think it
makes my mind does something good for my
brain yeah I feel like in my mind it
makes them kind of settle down it puts
them like on a pace that feels like they
can keep up with yeah whereas like this
the way we kind of uh have media
nowadays sometimes it feels like a pace
that's not fair to the yeah the the
operating system that I have you know
that God put in me or whatever
um any hotties ever pick you up any
chicks ever pick you up was there ever
any sex on the route no
definitely not it was mostly like a
super old-timey like sticking stick and
middle
kind of like formerly Vagabond hobo
dudes you know because I think that like
they they grew up before Texas Chainsaw
Massacre came out which to me is the
quintessential turning point of
hitchhikers being viewed as like
potentially homicidal Maniacs but before
that I'm assuming it was a cool [ __ ]
hippie thing to do you know but then
after that it was like hitchhiker is a
is a murderer yeah and so I think now
like people would flip me off you know
like good we're talking like Christian
Family Folk we'll be driving in a
minivan look at me and the whole family
would flip me off oh that yeah just
strange look at that yeah
yeah they used to call yeah I remember
yeah people sometimes drive by call me a
road inward they were coming up like
what what do you even thought wow
so you you did submission yeah man I
used to get out there bro I used to love
it I used to love
you know what I think I loved I think I
did it because there was a part of me
that wanted to
have something different you know yeah
but then there was that moment of fear
where it's like I don't know what the
heck's gonna happen to me yeah I think I
always like that you know Gamble
like one dude that picked us up in
Arizona drove me from Phoenix to Vegas
he was like uh basically an arms dealer
you know and he had just spent the
better part of 10 years like in Arizona
State Penitentiary and his whole back
seat had like Home Depot uh buckets just
full of like magazines switches
silencers beams all this crazy ass [ __ ]
and was it hard to navigate that is it
hard to stay in the pocket in there and
not just like jump out or well because
you know one thing you learned from
being a hitchhiker is people lie a lot
they try to impress you they try to
relate to you and they want to seem
super cool and like weathered so they
would tell you like man I used to be
selling guns all up and down the West
Coast you're like okay you know we hear
you right and then he was like no for
real check out the back and I look at
these buckets full of like gun parts and
I'm like why the [ __ ] did this guy pick
me up yeah and he was already running
hot riding hot as hell right but I guess
he probably enjoyed the roll of the dice
too oh right there's two people are
rolling the dice and it's also like
saying hey God I'm gonna put the dice or
Fates or whatever I'm gonna put the dice
in your hands exactly I'm gonna let I'm
gonna take if I I'm gonna like
yeah I'm gonna take my hands off the
wheel yeah dude a lot of times I would
let people just or I would get picked up
or have people take me just even around
our own town you know and it was
definitely
uh yeah there's that element of
uncertainty what's gonna happen here you
know and also it takes some of the
responsibility of your own life off of
you you're like I'm gonna put my life in
this guy's hands this Mazda yeah you
know this dude in a mile you know with
underglow yeah
damn bro yeah and hitchhiking needs to
be so popular in the 70s and stuff like
that like 1978 or whatever Texas
Chainsaw Massacre drop that's when it
happened huh and then every year there
was a hitchhiker horror movie of some
hippie looking dude who likes you know
slashes the driver's throat oh it's
horrible but also in the south I mean
hitchhiking is a lot harder than it is
on the west coast you think so I did the
101 one time like from Astoria Oregon
down to like the bay I got picked up
within 30 seconds every time by people
in like Volkswagen Vans and RVs like you
know West Coast kind of like hippie
adjacent folk in the South I feel like
it's more of a charity thing like when I
remember I got picked up in Paducah
Kentucky one time which is like the most
religious small town I've ever been to
and everyone who picked me up was like
you you remind me of my son I'm like
what do you mean they're like he's
strung out on dope somewhere and I'm
like okay I'm not but like thank you so
I think it's just a different barometer
you remind me of my hot daughter in that
area dude you would probably compete
with some of the local models I think I
think so too I could model in Paducah
all right if all else fails I can just
go model in the Appalachia yeah
gotta get stronger hands you know once I
get like farmer fingers bro how pissed
are they get would they get if like a
trans model showed up and started
winning all the pageants oh dude culture
War 2.0 that'd be so good the culture
War has been uh is back on I mean you've
been watching the news yeah I think I
see a lot of it so when you say culture
War what does it mean it means when
mainstream media propagates like
um irrelevant uh small culture War [ __ ]
you know like things that aren't like
really a big issue like you know like
trans women playing in sports and they
obsess over it to distract you from real
things that are going on do you think
that they do that yeah totally do it
like yeah like left like liberal and
like conservative mainstream media they
pick strategically like before midterms
to get people all riled up by like
zooming in on like specific they know
what they're doing yeah like people with
lisps like they're you know or like uh
yeah like trans people in sports yeah
doesn't this make you angry like you
didn't hear about it for like eight
months and then they're like oh [ __ ] we
got an election coming up let's Stoke
more anxiety and like exploit people's
fears about about this yeah I try to get
votes and it works huh instantly
on both sides yeah
yeah it works instantly on both sides
it's amazing sometimes because people
look at
the conservative side I feel like this
is just a general thought of my own
people get the conservative side as
being a less educated side
but both sides will fall for the same
exact tricks yep
it's almost crazy you can almost I don't
know it's just really fascinating to me
that it's like
but you this is the same game being done
on both on both teams oh yeah totally
like liberal media will go to like the
furthest sticks and Boonies they can
they can possibly go to to find like
they're like racist guy to interview
yeah and just to get people all freaked
out and I'm sure you know what that's
like they often scapegoat the South
yeah this happened a lot it's happened a
lot over the years especially during
like uh during Trump during like that
Administration during that kind of stuff
yeah those white guys in Charlestown or
whatever like Charlottesville yeah yeah
I thought it was surely like there's
probably a couple of dudes in there who
was hoping things would go to another
level of like yeah of let's wide it like
you know Whiting around yeah but I think
there was a probably as many people that
were just confused and responded to a
Craigslist ad you know yeah for sure
um and just following falling victim to
their own Echo chamber you know like
they're in these tight weird online
Niche communities and the algorithm
starts recommending [ __ ] to them that
they already know they're going to be
receptive to to get more ad revenue and
before you know it they're just like
down the rabbit hole and these social
media companies are making [ __ ]
Millions while these people were just
spiraling out of control yeah the next
thing you know they're yelling [ __ ]
about Jews in public I mean that's crazy
dude you know I don't yell anything in
public yeah yeah Michael Myers is pretty
I don't honestly bro the dude not that
scary anymore I saw the last Halloween
it was horrible the one few years ago
was horrible
I can't imagine how bad this one is
but
if you look at him
he looks like the kind of dude that
tightens his body up because he's got
that whacker on him bro
he's got that uh he's got that Tremor
baby that that he got a damn machete
doesn't he
what I'm telling you about is manscaped
is the safe way to do it that man could
easily whack his wiener off but you
won't
manscape launched their fourth
generation performance package to make
sure your pumpkins
get the ultimate carving experience on
this spooky time of year
that's right turn your bite size treat
into a king-sized candy that means get
your wand looking long long one
join the Six Million Man worldwide who
trust manscaped by going to
manscaped.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code Theo
that's manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code Theo make the
right call this spoozies this spooky
season it's trick or trim now a word
from our sponsor betterhelp
you know one time I remember we got
stuck somewhere in the mud
when people said well dang we got to get
out the mud and I said well this is a
four cylinder this is a Ford Escort
and we don't stand a chance against the
mud
we in
this is the damn devils
gumbo got us stuck
got our tires just begging for help
that can happen to your brain sometimes
your brain gets stuck and you need
something
greater than you to help you that's
where better help comes in
better Help Therapy a therapist can help
you become a better Problem Solver
making it easier to get out that in mud
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online when you want to be a
better problem solver visit
betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
today to get the 10 off your first month
that's better
help.com
Theo well yelling in public also is such
an outdated form of communication
unfortunately yeah our voices now have
to go through these certain portals or
it feels like that they can't be
communicated yeah there's no more like
Town town crier I mean no one would take
you seriously right that's the thing no
one would take you seriously but I seek
out people like that yeah that's sort of
the basis of early all gas bill breaks
interviews is like I don't want to talk
to an online loud person I want to talk
to a real life screamer yeah so you get
so so yeah get me to all gas no breaks
and then let's get to channel five so
and then uh just for our listeners so
you you you're doing the hitchhiking
you've left out of Louisiana
and you end up in Seattle in Seattle and
then from Seattle like down to LA on the
west coast and back to Colorado I I mean
The Summer's following that I hitchhiked
a bunch but the book that I wrote and
it's not for sale anymore but it was
about like my first hitchhiking
experience uh that kind of had like a
small cult following which led me to
want to make a ship the book was called
August snow Breaks A Hitchhiker's diary
yeah and I was like man nobody really
reads I want to make a like an
interview-based Road Show so I convinced
the company to buy me an RV whatever
made all gas no breaks fell out with the
company over a contractual dispute right
signed a movie deal with Tim and Eric
that movie is coming out in December
awesome it's with HBO and 824 and
congratulations I'm stoked dude it's
crazy wow yeah and so the movie will be
about I know you have a tour coming up
too right yeah yeah so I mean that's
crazy man I start my first ever tour in
like 12 days it's like 45 dates like
back to back we're gonna screen scenes
from the movie we're gonna find like
battle rappers and magicians via
Craigslist yeah to open up each
performance you can have some people
from episode I know that you've already
taped that will be at some of the uh at
some of the venues yeah definitely and
it's just crazy I've just been like
trying to be calm before the tour starts
I just been playing tennis and hanging
out with my mom every day oh wow yeah at
Venice Beach tennis courts do you and
your mother look alike or no yeah for
sure y'all do yeah that's cool I think
so yeah yeah
um is your father still alive or no yeah
he's alive he's a bartender in Seattle
oh he is yeah oh wow he's a cool dude
are your parents pretty proud of you
yeah I think so I hope so yeah they
should be I think yeah you know what I
mean do you feel like your desire to
create or to get out there and interview
people do you feel like any of that came
from your own childhood or do you think
it was just a choice you kind of made as
you like is it more about journalism or
is it more about seeking something to
fulfill something inside of you well I
think my mom is like a super sweet like
caring person very empathetic big
listener she's she was the kind of
person that like you know if someone
would approach us on the street you know
like I need some help she would always
help them but a step further like talk
to them and Converse with them and so
like I think when I was super young she
would humanize people just day to day
for me so I didn't go I didn't grow up
with this wall or like glass wall
between me and like people who I didn't
understand right so I just kind of went
through life and then like when I
started smoking weed when I was like 13
in Seattle like walking around downtown
High I just became like this like a
toddler level curious like wander and I
would just walk around like what's up
where are you from what's and I would
ask people what's the craziest thing
you've ever seen I was young like what's
crazy I've ever seen I'll just sit there
for like an hour I'm like damn dude all
right peace so I was like listening to
basically five hours of free podcast
today and so by the time I got old I was
like damn you can make a career out of
this like that's sick wow that's
incredible man yeah Seattle's got
Seattle at night gets really it's got a
like a damp vampire
there's a lot of damn condensation
[ __ ] drug Muppets bouncing around
over there certainly so it's a beautiful
American city yeah yeah
we used to do that comedy club
underground underground comedy over
there yeah it was it was honestly one of
the best rooms to do comedy in I think
it's still there
um so now so so so that's where you're
at now so now you got like I mean you
you do so much interesting stuff now you
follow is that still kind of your your
goal to follow the the heat to follow
what's going on how hard is it to still
do that when you've gotten busier uh I'm
not I mean right now there's not much
happening in the news cycle so it's like
I'm more doing like character studies
and like random cultural interest stuff
but like once the midterms kick back
into full swing like I gotta follow the
newsbeat like there's nothing better
than like being on the ball of news as
it's happening like it's it's like the
best feeling it's like it's kind of like
a nickname wow like watching history
unfold and documenting it and being like
on scene I get how reporters can get
addicted to like following that high all
the time but you gotta like stay away
from that to a certain degree because
then you become just like a chaos
tourist and he spent every waking day
being like where are people pissed off
and you get so used to it's kind of
Jades your mind and you're like man like
Society is in decline because you spend
every other day at like a right or
left-wing protest so it's important to
kind of zoom out and cover like pause of
subjects like I went to a powerlifting
event in Sacramento a month ago called
world's strongest man that was just fun
no one's talking about like you know the
Clinton deep state cabal or like the
collapse of civilization so I'm like man
this is just nice so you gotta pepper
your life with [ __ ] like that to stay
level-headed I think interesting D yeah
I saw you talking a bunch of like those
jizz wizard dudes those like guys that
are like those [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying yeah garglers dude them dudes go
deep Bro yeah will blunderfield this is
oh okay will will he's kind of the
commander-in-chief of the jizz Wizards
and uh and that's a new movement really
of men did you see that just as a while
like an out there group or do you see
that as a as as an example of men trying
to find different ways to regain
masculinity I think for I think that
will will specific demographic is dudes
who would be traditionally called Gay by
Society okay trying to become bisexual
to a certain extent you know what I mean
because he's talking about how you know
when he does same-sex erotic bonding in
the forest with his Bros it kind of
makes him have appropriate Verge you
know so I think to a certain degree
I think the manosphere has definitely
taken over like a lot of the surface net
even what is the manosphere just like
Andrew type people you know just like
men's
like Alpha men's Wellness self-help
dudes you know but I think that Will's a
bit different because it's more on like
the spiritual side and it's more
connected to like
eating well and all that type of [ __ ]
cutting like glyphosate and natrazine
out of your diet to like have your
chakra as aligned and like reach the new
dimension and like breath work and I
feel like he I feel like he's more on
that tip but then again I feel like 2020
and covid created this insane fusion
with like the Wellness Community
and like pretty hard right people
because of the anti-vaxx thing oh
interesting so like half of the you know
like yogis and like holistic Community
Wellness people became like fully q and
on pilled in 2020. wow like I remember I
I'm not gonna say her name but the one
this lady who invented butthole sunning
or perennium sunny yeah I've heard a lot
about that yeah so she it was super like
kind of cool hippie like free thinker
believes in the Sun God thinks the Sun
God speaks to your soul through your
anus Reyes come in get into your body
that's got Divine energy
I hadn't talked to her in like six
months I checked back on her Instagram
and it's a this is real [ __ ] it's George
Floyd and then like a lizard person
cropped over each other and she was like
don't believe everything you see on TV
and like it's just crazy to see like
that happening to someone like that and
now it's all just like the storm is
coming like crazy ass like Fringe [ __ ]
like JFK Jr is still alive
oh wow like uh Yankee Junior
no he's no he's not but his him being
alive is Central to the Q Anon oh I see
okay I see that you're just saying that
it gets in that little that uh drain
they were waiting at the grassy knoll in
Dallas like four months ago for his
return no way yeah and like it's kind of
like Bigfoot hunting style where like
one guy says that he saw it when
everyone looked away and so I met a guy
who was like I saw him and everyone's
like no you didn't like and they almost
were having some infighting he's like
nah dude I saw him you were down there
when that happened no but I talked to a
bunch of the people who were there at
the people's Convoy which is like a
trucker protest right after okay yeah
wow I'm pretty deep in that little world
yeah we've well we've had Bobby Kennedy
on here before so he was big he's a
environmentalist you know so it's in it
makes sense that he would be you know he
was always about like taking care of
nature so then it makes sense that he
would take want to take that his
interest would lead to taking care of
the nature inside of your body you know
like the waterways inside of your body
and that sort of thing um
so he's been a big like I wouldn't call
him an ant I don't know I don't know if
he was anti he wasn't anti-cover but I
think he was in anti-vaxx anti or making
sure that vaccinations are tested
correctly yeah
um because in my town I grew up in a in
in Covington Louisiana and they had they
used to they were making the polio
vaccine in our town in like the 60s or
something whenever they put it out or
maybe the I think the 60s or 70s
um
and they that's where they created the
polio vaccine at and they used to test
it on monkeys well the polio vaccine
ended up giving cervical cancer to
millions of women but they'd already
made it and they were just like yeah
[ __ ] it we already bought it right yeah
we already the deal sealed yeah this is
what we got so it helped polio but you
there was a high risk for cervical
cancer so I think some people you know
it it also depends I think where some
people's mindsets come out of yeah
um do you uh do you now like like I know
you just went in and interviewed Alex
Jones and had to sit down with Alex
Jones yeah what was that kind of like
was that do you think the guy was
absolutely crazy do you think he was
overwhelmed by the the lawsuit at this
point
um or do you feel like he's on point
with some stuff and he's just too loud
for the world these days like
I don't know it's such a tough one
because I I do see both angles of it you
know what I mean and I had a lot of heat
from a lot of my fans for even talking
to him I mean the billion dollar verdict
it's he probably has between two and
three million dollars and Infowars or
Free Speech systems is filing for
bankruptcy so he's not gonna the the
Sandy Hook families aren't going to see
that money right but um I guess it's a
precedent in the future
for it's like if you because he was
really coming after the parents as well
right you know like he put one of the
parents addresses up I mean it's
egregious I mean it's egregious when
somebody go and I can't imagine when you
go through something like that yeah and
there's this voice that gets loud yeah
but I'm reading this book called Sandy
Hook by Elizabeth Elizabeth Williamson
and like some of the dudes that Alex was
like platforming on his [ __ ] I hate
saying platforming but like let's do the
Wolfgang Helbig and there's people who
like were threatening like 4 000 emails
a day to the Sandy Hook family's like
type [ __ ] like harassing them stalking
them leaving messages saying they're
gonna kill them accusing them of keeping
their kids alive as sex slaves in the
attic and [ __ ] horrible stuff so there
wasn't a lot of people it's not just
about Alex it's just somebody it's about
people the ripple effect yeah because
there's a whole community of lost people
who devote their whole life to harassing
the uh victims families of the Colorado
Aurora shooting of Sandy Hook of Uvalde
like it's a whole community of you know
crisis actor follower was like false
flag have you been able to meet any of
those types of folks even just to see
like because I think one thing that's
really interesting that you do and I
really like seeing it man is that you
kind of just you go and just kind of
listen to people it's like hey here's
what's going on and I think it's really
powerful even as you say like some of
your followers or or supporters like oh
why would you even give this guy a space
but people would say that too about
having Bobby Kennedy on here why would
you give this guy's face like he's a
human being he's first of all one of the
smartest guys that I know yeah like
really interesting and amazing friend
yeah so it's like I wouldn't not trust
him like why wouldn't I listen and hear
what his what his thoughts are and
what's going on I just think like the
more liberal audience is like super into
uh
de-platforming and they think that like
giving someone a giving a problematic
person a platform is somehow supporting
them and I always refute that like this
if I if it's a lesser-known shitty
person then I'm cherry-picking to kind
of dunk on that's [ __ ] up you know if
I'm if I bring some white nationalist
from the you know cuts of Alabama on my
show just to like Grill him and make him
look stupid right I am inadvertently
growing his audience by bringing him on
because the people who watch my [ __ ] and
and even if they agree with me his name
is now out there I've elevated his name
to the top and so people will know his
name and go to his website you kind of
increase traffic for that person right
and you create future white nationalists
and vice versa but like Alex Jones
everybody knows who that is he's a
household name the proud boys everybody
knows who that is so when I'm
interviewing people like that that most
of my audience doesn't like I am not
increasing their fame or increasing
their exposure because with or without
me everyone's gonna know who those
people are right Alex Jones is on the
front page of the New York Times the
proud boys are being investigated by the
FBI for January 6. so me interviewing
them I'm not platforming or increasing
Their audience at all but you know if I
was to interview like more lesser known
you know Fringe people I wouldn't do
that you know yeah like if you were to
interview like Whitey killer 1200 or you
were to interview like um slave buyer 55
exactly then you would be you know or
yeah but mainstream media like liberal
media does that [ __ ] they find like the
dumbest person they can and they're like
inside the Klu Klux Klan and it's and
it's like some like 300 pound like CSI
Miami Watchers and his cherries like why
people we're just better at stuff
and the journalist is like what do you
mean by that how can you say something
like that he was like
you know I'm not doing that [ __ ] man
yeah it's interesting and it's like
people that why do people get so stuck
in their own like why can't people just
let somebody else have a different
belief like like a different politician
how did that get so crazy from your
perception I don't know but I think that
uh the politics like the how all the
late night TV shows and how SNL just
became like orange man bashing machines
yeah and you [ __ ] turn on Colbert or
Jimmy Kimmel or something it's literally
like every other night is like an
anti-trump monologue it was horrible
they ruined their shows I think they're
still doing it
they're crazy though it seems like bad
but why it's like
you could just say hey this is who I
supporter don't support yeah I think the
incentive is there it's the safest thing
you can do you know in comedy in in that
realm is to just bash like you know a
conservative president and I don't
support Trump you know but it's like I
don't want to go on late night TV and
watch the rich guy talk [ __ ] about
another rich guy I know you know what I
mean I'm just like this is just the same
[ __ ] and I think that has something to
do with it
because if you think about it right like
those shows reach everybody they're on
cable so you can be sitting in the
middle of a red State and you go on
cable and you go to Comedy Central ABC
late night and that's what you're seeing
is you're a supposed hero being [ __ ] on
by you know the comedic Elite of late
night TV in Los Angeles or New York
right and that they're all on the same
page none of them have any different
view or not even a lot of uh like
variation variation in their own views
yes
but like the real OG is like Jon Stewart
like they've held it now you know that
to me that's like the best yeah early
Daily Show
to me that was like during the bush era
that was like this absolute sweet spot
of like comedic late night political
[ __ ] yeah and Bush also was they kind of
made like it was different with Trump
people I mean they
Hollywood just decided they [ __ ] their
yeah either something either we don't
have enough ownership over this guy or
he's too much of a loose cannon whatever
it is but that not a
excuse me not a chance or or are we
everybody's gonna hate this dude and
then everybody works with Holly so they
have no choice yeah that's who pays
their bills yeah it's also hard to
satirize a guy who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about everyone thinks right you know
what I mean it's like you think he gives
a [ __ ] he just likes the attention from
it you know right I think yeah that's
really interesting too but I think that
turned off a lot of people even if
people like
weren't that political it was just like
well why are you so one-sided like what
do you what what do you have in this
yeah and there's you can there's real
venom in some of those monologues dude
oh yeah you're like Jesus Christ this is
like mean-spirited almost man like oh
yeah I thought that it was I think it
ruined Hollywood for a lot of people
it's like it made a lot of people think
like well obviously this is a group that
doesn't support me yeah do you think
that your move to Nashville was like a
little bit inspired by that stuff
I think well I wanted to honestly save
money yeah and everybody went to Austin
and I never wanted to be like everybody
else and everybody did it you know Joe
Rogan moved there and Tim Dylan went
there and uh Tom Segura and I think I
always wanted to be a little bit
different yeah you know
um
I was scared that if I you know
I don't know I want to go look at Austin
now I'm gonna go check it out for a
month and see
um and then Nashville I don't know I
think there's
there's something really nice about it
it's just a lot of nice folks you've
been liking it yeah I think it's nice I
think
it does a lot of
this is a lot of nice people there like
I have like the nicest neighbors I've
ever had yeah
um it gives me a little bit of a
different idea of what's uh
of what the America's still like kind of
you know that's nice does it feel
Southern to you
yeah it does sometimes it I would never
was like redneck growing up like our
family didn't have any money we were
just poor white yeah yeah so we were
like
you know like we didn't have a boat like
a boat or any you know we didn't have
like a flag that we supported we didn't
have you know my father was from
Nicaragua he was 70 years old when I was
born my mother was from Illinois
and was making love to a poor old man
like you know yeah who's having sex with
a seven-year-old with no money yeah
you know what I'm saying like it's a bad
deal no matter who you are yeah I know
it's not good it's like it just seems
like a poor business choice you know man
that's a shitty age to have no money I
know yeah and it's just like anyway so
so yeah I think um what are some things
that I like about it it's nice for
touring too we can take tour buses right
out of there yeah uh and it's one of the
last Southern cities that still feels
kind of
like um I don't know it has like a new
rebirth yeah like I've gone to a lot of
these cities like uh Montgomery
um Jackson you've been there even
Savannah during the daytime downtown
kind of like uh Jackson yeah yeah
Charleston and Charleston's popping
Birmingham is pretty good too yeah
Birmingham I hear is pretty good I
haven't been really spending time there
in the city but there's a lot of
Southern cities uh Columbus Georgia that
are just like ghost towns yeah you know
especially Mississippi oh Mississippi is
a really ghost State like the north part
of it like the Delta yeah shelled out
towns it's gotten really bad man
um yeah Mississippi's is crazy man a
really bad branding happened I think
with a lot of like a lot of the South
was based on even a lot of the tourism
was based on tradition like War
battlefields and Antebellum homes things
like that that I think white people
didn't realize maybe as much
at that black maybe Black Culture didn't
have like
or maybe have angered them I don't know
I think a lot of that kind of came out
during BLM when a lot of like statues
were being torn down and like um
you know so I think the South also is in
a little bit of a space where it's like
well
I don't think I was grasping on to the
history there because it was racist I
just thought it was the history like
Robert E Lee that was the statue like
yeah you know we would all meet up there
Mardi Gras I don't think half of us knew
what the [ __ ] he did yeah you know
um but I think so a lot of the tradition
there feels like it's been stirred yeah
and I think a lot of people down there
don't really know what to do in some
Southern places right now yeah I wonder
when they're gonna start landmarking
like a like hip-hop achievements and
[ __ ] like when I was in I was in
Clarksdale and Yazoo City and the Delta
and it's everything is like the you know
the delta blues Trail like here's where
lightning Hopkins like grew up and I'm
like what about Lil Wayne yeah like at
what point are we gonna start like
markings Logan's house and Holly Grove
and [ __ ] because like that stuff really
changed the world in a similar way that
Blues did you know it's not even a
bigger impact but like I'm amazed they
haven't done that I think about it all
the time like hip-hop Heritage Trail
it's gonna happen eventually we're gonna
be tripping bro we're gonna be like 90
years old if they're like in the third
world they're gonna be like here stood
with the Magnolia projects where soldier
Slim and Master P and C murder came out
with their first No Limit Records album
we're gonna be like what the [ __ ] but it
has to happen right well it see it
almost seemed like it's behind schedule
especially since they've gone through so
many of those projects and stuff over
the years and torn like had to tear them
down or refurbish you think somebody
would have said hey let's just take this
building yeah and make it make some
money for the city you know especially
yeah they should have preserved like one
of the Old Magnolia buildings oh yeah
big boy where juvenile grew up yeah I
mean that's like the backdrop to like
the birth of [ __ ] Southern rap music
dude I would go there in a heartbeat
because it's so funny because I've gone
to the ones where like Elvis was born
yeah uh and you'll see signs like muddy
Gussy grew up here like people you don't
even know anymore yeah but if they had
like big boy like uh if they had a lot
of different ones along that trail it's
one of those classic things of like
who's really gonna campaign on that
though it's like in Seattle you can't
drink in strip clubs
what congressman is going to be like I'm
going to make this my issue
you know what I mean but I think these
days I think you make that small
pinpoint issue that catapults you from
being some Muppet with like uh or you
know just somebody to be in like all you
need is that one yeah and then you're in
the game as long you gotta you gotta
have some backup plans yeah for sure but
dude I can't believe that they have
strip clubs where you can't drink it
like
this like
but the the the strippers are all on
pill they can [ __ ] do pills but I
can't remember God in a white cloth yeah
I thought this is America now I feel you
my dad works next to a strip club my dad
works at a bar connected to a strip club
yeah and so it's always like bar strip
club back to bar back to strip club it's
like just tear the wall down
oh dude we went to a strip club once in
uh in Virginia we were touring a couple
of months ago and they're like uh in uh
oh Edgar Allan Poe used to own this a
strip club yeah his his like his
I think it's Edgar Allan Poe is he from
Virginia
no I grew out in post from Baltimore
okay well at one point he lived I guess
in Virginia and he like lived there for
a while or something yeah like oh we
used to live here it was like a historic
building yeah but then part of it was a
strip club it's pretty cool I didn't
even know Edgar Allan Poe got down like
that I think he got down the coast a
little bit went looking for a little bit
of push yeah he had a twisted mind oh he
had to dude it must have been a Twist to
this strip club dude he was like one of
the first BLM activists look at the
[ __ ] that the Raven or whatever was
that about race it was about black birds
yeah it was actually a pretty good
anti-racist number you know what I'm
saying yeah when all the right when
everybody's writing about red robins and
you start rocking about the Bia about
the about the Raven so was he like
were authors like rappers back then like
you think if you went to the strip club
everyone was like oh [ __ ] it's Edgar and
things like making it rain or what was
the strip club like before that kind of
music oh I don't know violin violin I
just can't Envision like you know yeah
just that slow with no future like what
does a strip club look like the artist
Future right right yeah 100 I don't know
that's a great question
a hunting we will go maybe a hunt just
like maybe somebody's singing stuff like
that like folksy accordion yeah huh you
ever been in the Claremont Lounge in
Atlanta yeah that's a good one it is a
good one what's Bourdain's favorite spot
was it really yeah yeah it used to have
that old uh an older lady in there and
she'd get those beer cans for you yeah
and they're a good place to watch people
do Coke that shouldn't be doing it yeah
for sure what's weird for me in strip
clubs is I only like them if they're
like super novelty
you know yeah I like getting like an
atmosphere sense like it's like Sopranos
bada bing Style just like the lighting
and like just degenerate people I like
to watch the people at strip clubs yeah
more of a burlesque style or something
no I mean like I like to I like to look
at the dudes who are at who are watching
strippers more than the strippers oh wow
because it's so interesting
yeah there's something about somebody
being right there to like
it's almost like a sense of like I don't
know I guess some people go probably for
desperation yeah they have just like
this weird like slack jaw and like a
permanently half full whiskey neat
Jameson glass and they're just like
absolutely mesmerized with like this wet
stack of ones because their Palm is
sweating you know the ring in their back
pocket just like
nothing in front of nothing behind them
just in the moment
you know what I mean yeah there's some
feeling right there huh yeah because
they they must know that the girls don't
actually like them
yeah so I guess a lot of is the myth of
it maybe it's they want to feel like a
rock star like Nickelback style yeah
like they're at the strip club by
themselves but I mean imagine going to a
strip club by yourself ordering a
Jameson and smoking a cigar Lake
yeah but idyllic like it's like some
Hemingway [ __ ] it's like yeah yeah like
this is me I'm I do this this isn't
weird at all this is cool this is what
rock stars do yeah you know but then the
women are all peeled up it's not even
this like exchange of emotion anymore
it's just two people sharing each other
hoping one of them has a has a perk on
them you know yeah that's what I feel
like it's almost like playing perk chess
with their eyes yeah I've never even
taken a prescription pill before you
know just playing just with that two 120
milligram stare how does that make you
feel Percocet like I don't know I took
two Somas one time and actually drove
off a road on accident and my buddy I
think R.I.P tried to give me a BJ or
something I don't even remember fully
but I wouldn't take them yeah I'm saying
that's what I'm saying I just have
friends who take them I've had had a
friend take them I looked them I'm like
well how are you feeling right now it's
crazy I think it disconnects you from
any senses that you have anything wrong
yeah there's nothing wrong man that's
not a good thing no you're made out of
marshmallows and [ __ ] homemade [ __ ]
dude I think you have everything that's
perfect you know I wanted to ask you so
what happened to the king and the sting
podcast it's no longer oh the king and
the sting podcast yeah the the the
podcast is still going I'm just not I'm
not doing it you're a brand new cool
though yeah yeah
we just
honestly man I missed I couldn't I
didn't have enough attention really to
focus yeah like I like I like my own
podcast and we have a unique kind of
audience I think yeah and I think I
wanted to be able to I feel a lot more
in touch with this now yeah like it's
important to me yeah and it was still
important but it was just a lot to try
and juggle yeah I liked uh the Gringo
poppy actually yeah yeah yeah oh I think
I people give Brennan so much
uh Flack and I think that's one of the
reasons I admire him in some ways yeah
is how you could withstand so much
uh disdain from people you know or fake
disdain yeah it's pretty psychotic
crazy isn't it yeah it goes back to the
people you were talking about yeah no
for sure it's kind of why I stopped like
I still have Instagram and stuff I just
don't go on it
because like when you run that when
you're like a major public figure or
whatever me a big media figure like if
someone comments on your [ __ ] you're
amazing at its best that's an ego boost
unhealthy ego boost and if someone says
you suck then that's an anxiety Spike so
it's like there's no once you've kind of
passed that threshold of like validation
from the public it's nothing but bad for
your mind because this little box in
your pocket it's like oh you're the [ __ ]
man you're the best journalist I'm
walking around by myself getting
endorphins from that which is not
natural it should be like you know
touching trees playing tennis with my
mom but instead it's like and then if
someone then if that box is like [ __ ]
you man you're a libtard you're sellout
or something I'm like oh man like I
don't I feel bad about myself yeah so
there's no healthy like Middle Ground I
don't think for me at least I'm too
sensitive
man I'm too sensitive to it too I and I
I still let it affect you know I let it
affect me a lot of times I notice like
you're saying to have somewhere with all
that I go there for certain things
um did you just kind of pick that up or
did you always know it or did you did
did you kind of like like did did you
notice that happening you're like yeah
this isn't good I stopped on Instagram
one month ago wow because I was just
like damn dude like every day I wake up
it's the first thing I check
let's say what are people saying about
me today like yeah am I still okay oh
yeah like am I still okay Do my fans
still [ __ ] with me like uh do they like
the video I just dropped you know what I
mean like like did something come out in
the middle of the night of me picking my
nose or something yeah I can't go
anywhere or just or just like you know
like how are my stats doing or but even
more specifically like like it started
actually when I ran when I dropped Alex
Jones interview and everyone was like
why would you platform Emoji platform
and then people other people were like
you're a [ __ ] G for giving this guy a
voice and I was like I can't deal with
this I just want to like make cool stuff
and I I still check YouTube comments and
stuff like that but I'm I'm not trying
to like be constantly engaged in my own
feedback loop it's so unhealthy dude
yeah it's scary it puts you at the
center of the universe even if you're no
matter what level you're at you could be
a small level dude but if every day
you're engaging with people who love or
hate you and I don't have much hate I
have a lot of love but that makes hate
stick out so much more you know it's
like I could see like a thousand
positive comments and then if I see one
negative comment like those words are
like etched into my brain like the whole
next two days it's so true I just can't
turn it off I'm like damn did I did I
[ __ ] up this interview like am I falling
off yeah I mean like and I just had to
stop dude it's amazing how that can
overwhelm how that can overwhelm
whatever all the proof that we would
think we have built into our system of
because of our own like lives you know
it's amazing man you know if you have a
high balance on your credit card it can
really be devilish
it can be that thing every month you're
throwing money away throwing it down to
the dogs to the debt dogs
well that can change
a credit card consolidation from light
stream can help you pay off your credit
cards and lock in a low fixed interest
rate that's right rates start at 6.99
APR with auto pay and excellent credit
you can get a loan from five thousand to
one hundred thousand that's a that's a
real amount
and there are absolutely no fees
you can even get your money as soon as
the day that you apply
just for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to
lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's light stream
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo
subject to credit approval rates range
from 6.99 APR to 19.99 APR and include
point five percent auto pay discount
lowest rates lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
Theo for more information be well life
is scary when you realize your dog might
have fleas and you might have them too
dang it
life is scary when you're eating uh
when you're eating yogurt and there's
something in it
and there ain't supposed to be nothing
in it
life is scary when um
when your cousin comes over and burns
your house down oh
that's a tough one
yep life is scary when it's your first
date
and your body hurts you you uh
you might have appendicitis
never know
what I'm talking about is the Sunday
scaries they can happen any day of the
week and I want to tell you about Sunday
scary CBD gummies
they were made to defeat the crap that
life throws at us they're the perfect
CBD gummies for professionals on the
grind super moms students party animals
regretful drunk sexters and everyone in
between I don't know how it's going to
help the sexting but it might
I don't relax well
and you might not either you are welcome
to try Sunday scaries CBD gummies look
we all have the right to live scare free
that's right so they recommend taking
two CBD gummies every day to keep the
scaries away
I can offer you this 25 discount visit
sundayscaries.com
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-c-a-r-i-e-s.com and use
promo code Theo for your discount that's
promo code t-h-e-o for 25 off at Sunday
scaries s-c-a-r-i-e-s.com
yeah no I think it's interesting I think
it's Brave to give to have guys on that
are different you know like yeah we get
pitch guys sometimes or or girls and I'm
like I don't know but then that's the
part where I need to lean in and say Yes
I want to have to talk because I want to
be able to share some of my truth and
and or and hear something different you
know yeah I think I think it's you do a
great job of of being in that space do
you feel like you ever go to a place
just to pick on a group never not
anymore I mean I like when I think when
I first started there was a lot of low
hanging fruit but I developed a respect
for interview subjects pretty quickly I
mean there's some groups that I it's
clear from you know how I'm talking to
them that I I'm trying to sort of poke
holes in what they're saying but no I
don't go try to pick on people you know
if anything I try to understand people
yeah you know because picking on people
is really easy like anything that
Society sees is weird like furries or
flat earthers it's very easy to show up
point fingers make fun them ask them
weird questions but when you ask the why
or how did you end up like this is when
it gets really interesting because you
get to just follow that why infinitely
until you get to the core of what drove
them to The Fringe and that's the [ __ ]
that fascinates me yeah because it's
always the same
what is it just Community
loneliness isolation
being ostracized by the traditional
group that they were around
online Echo Chambers loneliness personal
failure personal aspirations
common themes like old school [ __ ]
um yeah those are tropes that have been
around forever huh yeah that's what it
comes back to what does tropes mean does
that make any sense that makes sense all
right I'll take it oh it also comes back
to the Jews a lot really yeah because
they started it no like hella people
don't like Jews oh yeah Kanye was
talking about that
do you think that many people don't like
you
I think it's
I mean I think it's
because Woody Kanye they were getting on
Kanye
I mean he's been saying some horrible
[ __ ] yeah you know that Kanye [ __ ] is
sad but do you think people should just
be up but should he be shut down from
saying stuff or he can just say I guess
people are going to say whatever they
want if he says I'm about to go Defcon 3
on the Jews and he's telling his
audience that like
um yeah uh Hollywood music is totally
controlled by Jews like it is true that
there is like highly influential Jewish
people in Hollywood but it's controlled
by money people or capitalists of all
shapes and sizes and they're not loyal
to each other
but you know you think that that those
type that those that money people aren't
loyal to each other I mean in a sense of
collaboration but [ __ ] they're all
trying to race to the top that's how
it's working and the idea that is some
sort of cohesion there it's not really
true I mean like there is collaboration
but like what Kanye is talking about is
being exploited by you know predatory uh
recording I mean uh uh record companies
and [ __ ] like that and labels that's a
real thing the media and be invading his
life you know TMZ showing him to his
house at three o'clock in the morning
and asking him about his mental health
like every element of his private life
being publicized by media Outlets that's
a real thing right and so it's like he's
so close to talking about that but then
he is obviously someone in his ear being
like it's it's all about the Jews and
he's like and then my Jewish personal
trainer it's it's sad a lot of people
don't even know that they're being
anti-semitic and I also think the phrase
anti-semitic gets so overused yeah
people say it's tough because you can't
even sometimes it feels you can't even
say the word Jew or Jewish and you're
sudden like this person's anti-semitic
it's like well you could say black or
white or Christian or you know Muslims
or Slims some people call them yeah
but I'm just saying conspiracy thought
the idea that like every anomaly and
everything that goes a little bit weird
is not a result of human error it's a
calculated deep State plot every sort of
loophole there's loopholes in everyone's
reporting and everything has everything
goes wrong people think the CIA is doing
all this crazy [ __ ] they tried to kill
Castro and Cuba like 45 times the CIA
can't pull off anything correctly our
government can't do anything right yeah
yet somehow people think they're capable
of these massive like mind control
conspiracies I was like The Wider the
roads look like that
I just don't get how people think that
that this all-powerful deep State can
manipulate and control the entire planet
yeah that's true if you can't even get
me from like Saint George to El Paso
yeah then how are you gonna get me from
like uh the aliens to
um you know to the Octagon right people
are bad at secrets too man they have
people are bad at secrets that's a good
point I always think that a lot about
Secrets like why if somebody knew
something on their deathbed why are they
going to hold on to it especially
anymore I could see 50 years ago
when there was this more like loyalism
to America too like we are this thing
like people I felt like had bought into
like we are this text this thread this
woven blanket but now it seems like we
are
the like P that's that's disappearing
yeah like if they told Trump about the
aliens
he would tell in a half hour he wouldn't
[ __ ] tell us yeah he'd be like I will
not be you know a puppet of the CIA yeah
and there's a spacecraft below the White
House
it's been there for 30 years it's not
what he sounds like right that's how he
would say it yeah it is yeah totally
true but and that's why I don't think
they could get all these pilots and
people that have died over the years
that I don't think they could get any of
those people to keep a secret anymore do
you think no somebody would make a tick
tock at a half hour before they're dead
like my dad just told me this yeah it'll
be the kids of these uh Area 51 people
yeah we're like so my dad just dropped
the bomb on me like all that [ __ ]
Area 51 is so sick dude yeah have you
been over there I tried to go I went to
the raid of Area 51 in 2019 one of my
first I think I remember that things
and it was a letdown huh the only guy
who got arrested was this like recently
divorced father of three who was in like
a he was sleeping in the back of his
Subaru next to our RV and he was like
they're [ __ ] in there and I'm going
and he tried to storm it by himself and
he got like you know
machine guns in his face wow yeah
dang do you think did you get the
feeling when you were there that they're
holding something no I think they're
just you know experimenting with drones
why would it be Area 51 like there's
merch along the whole highway saying
those aliens there yeah they would have
moved him by now
through a different black box site
do you feel like we've had a lot of
encounters and oh yeah I feel like we've
had few a lot dude
totally
do you feel like that there are alien
figures amongst us that they have that
kind of technology to put people amongst
us that are actually beings from other
planets or worlds yeah I mean like you
ever looked into like the eyes of like a
like a Nordic dude
like a six foot seven
like a viking looking person cold blue
maybe six four maybe
that's evidence right there
yeah I gotta look deeper next time I
think I didn't I guess I didn't look
that deeply joke there's pretty much all
alien conspiracy theorists such as Bob
Brown in Nevada think that people from
Norway are aliens oh really or that they
possess some sort of reptilian or um old
school lumerian DNA wow which gives them
that sort of uh look that iridescent and
also the architectural capability
um
Ikea
yeah you want to follow the uh
the directions or whatever yeah you know
yeah damn
well I think sometimes that aliens come
here I think we are like aliens Advanced
far past us right like even if you see
us now we're becoming like Meeker
figures we only use our brains you see
an alien it's like just the brain looks
active the body just looks like this
dormant sort of like non-genital no tits
even anymore never just like the body
seems very like you don't notice it it's
just that kind of like diamond oval head
with the big eyes so there's a lot of
brain activity thinking yeah that's what
I feel like
so aliens they've moved off here a long
time ago I think they come by every now
and then to see like the plant like it's
almost like if your parents took you
like some shitty Water Park it's like a
poor poor alien families no offense yeah
but if Airline family's real poor then
they'll like or they didn't get tickets
to like the cool
planet to go see yeah then they stopped
the kid's like what the [ __ ] we're over
here yeah this place is weird as [ __ ]
yeah this place sucks yeah I see the
capital Riot Will Smith punching Chris
Rock yeah people are [ __ ] [ __ ] let's
get up out of here yes that's what I
think happens all the time some shitty
dad tries to bring his kids here and his
wife here to save their [ __ ] family
or to do yeah and he didn't plan ahead
and the kids likes to get the [ __ ] out
of here they land at Talladega race
weekend they're like what the [ __ ] uh no
but I would think the aliens would
actually be on a smaller level like on
microbial small level so they can you
know kind of look at us like they could
be like cell sized you know condensed
because they don't want to be identified
everyone assumes though he's like
gargantuan Cthulhu looking District nine
creatures were gonna come down
and like scare the [ __ ] out of us but
why they always look like shrimp in the
movies you know like giant lobsters yeah
I think they're really like floating
through the air like well dust particles
be like hey you know what I'm saying
dude that's more of a Vibe too and a
dust particle when you watch them how
they move they move like alien vessels a
lot of times they move with purpose yeah
that purposeful dust homie for real damn
that's almost what we are as humans
uh-huh we're [ __ ] we think we're
purposeful dust that's a fact damn bro
um when you went when you go into some
places do you ever have do you have a
lot of fear obviously I you know I
understand now from like you're growing
up and stuff like that and some of your
energy like
um like I remember from my dad my dad
would sell like do like credit card
signups at colleges and stuff you know
yeah when I was a kid and so uh we'd
roll over there and like we'd get all
this [ __ ] out and like you know he's 78
years old he's signing people up and I
would get up on the table and bark at
college kids going by to get them to
come and sign up and they get like a
free hat or something that's fun that
says like Chase Bank you know something
it's like a Frisbee now it would be cool
back then it was horrible for sure but
now it would be a fire hat and uh
so I could see where you being in your
environments growing up and like having
like um interaction with people yeah
where it makes you fit into your world
now real comfortably are there places
you've got in that make you have made
you kind of fearful or scared like
honestly not really because like with
the camera rolling people aren't really
going to test you I think that like
the most on Earth I've ever been was
like I was uh I wasn't trying to do SEC
games for a while so like I was at the
roll Tide I was at the Auburn Roll Tide
game in Tuscaloosa so a home game for
Alabama Alabama lost a home game
and so like people were fighting in the
streets like you know you know how it
goes oh yeah college football in the
south is a real serious thing I'm
watching 50 60 year old dudes who you
know were in there for in France four
years ago Rumble out old beefs yeah in
front of the Waffle House of Tuscaloosa
I'm like man this is tough and people
when people were fighting right in front
of you my first thought is I want to
interview them while they're fighting
right you know so I want to be like hey
what's going on how'd this start and
then they would feed what I mean so I
mean we had a couple situations in
Tuscaloosa where people would try to
take our cameras and like who the [ __ ]
are you guys and we're like uh YouTubers
like get the [ __ ] out of our party you
know also they're very comfortable with
violence at Southern schools yeah
there's not really consequences for like
big brawls at schools in the south at
just in fraternity environments like
there would be on a regular Street
anywhere else yeah I think Southern
Culture does it's more like uh
especially in the South you're looking
at more like uh fight outside of the bar
yeah it's like Australians yeah you know
it's just like yeah they settle the
score after yeah it's like a bunch of
baked bean Australians kind of literally
and no one's called the cops really and
they kind of let things happen right
so like you know that's an only place
frats is probably the worst place for me
to film dude it's funny when I remember
growing yeah France is a weird energy
because it's also like
but then if they like you and they know
who you are then it is a different
energy can be different unless you test
that one dude who doesn't know yeah
that sometimes can be weird this was
like when we were pretty like lesser
known
so it was a lot scarier yeah probably
now if I were to like message some frat
in advance and being like I'm coming
back to uh Ole Miss maybe they'd be like
oh we're gonna show you the best party
ever yeah
um what about I saw you that you went
into oh block you went into like Chicago
and they have like a lot of like is that
one of the areas where they have a lot
of crime where they've had a lot of crop
violence yeah wow I wasn't scared there
or anything because like you know they
just took good care of us also nobody
wants to be perceived that way in media
so they're going to go above and beyond
to make sure that everyone knows that
like when I got to oblock everyone knew
that I was coming
and they were just like hey good to meet
you we checked your stuff out
welcome yeah that's interesting yeah
there you go right there dude that's
fire yeah I would say when they say the
hood or whatever is probably the least
scary place to film wow you know because
your intention is clear you know you're
a white guy with a camera crew it's like
everyone knows what that is nothing's
gonna happen to you that's a good point
where there's more commonality
there's more uh potential for violence
as a journalist
you know what I mean it's the classic
thing of like Louis Thoreau from England
yeah when he did his weird weekend
series him being British as an outsider
I think gave him a pass to kind of come
in and be more confrontational whereas
like I'm more likely to be in a violent
situation with someone who is a similar
looks like me and is in a similar age
range to me because they kind of feel
like oh it's more like buddy buddy like
broed out I haven't seen it with fans
like if any frat age white fan will come
up and just bear hug the [ __ ] out of me
you know they're just less of a barrier
whereas like anyone older or younger
will be a little bit more cautious or in
a different socio-economic place
that's interesting yeah it's interesting
how some fans interact or some
supporters of you will interact yeah
like the other day at the airport a guy
was just yelling at me like do but it
was like we knew each other but we
didn't know each other yeah but it was
like and he kept looking at me like I
should have acted a certain way but I
didn't really know how to like yeah it's
interesting how different people's
perceptions of running across somebody
that they've seen before yeah I think
for you too because you podcast like
people it's more parasocial because they
feel like they've spent so much time
with oh yeah because they get off work
they're driving home or whatever they're
listening to you like you're pretty much
there in the car with them they're
laughing along with you yeah or they're
laughing along with us like right now
you know yeah if somebody says I listen
to the podcast I immediately go into a
different place with them as well as
opposed to someone saying I saw your
stand-up special or somebody just saying
uh hey man I saw you on Tick Tock or I
saw you on this or that because Tick
Tock uh you know people have cut up I
think we're almost at like a billion
interact views on Tick Tock right for
the for just my name hashtag
so kind of cool but also like I didn't
create probably most of those 90 of that
yeah other people made stuff and put it
out there yeah so it's kind of weird so
it's like you get put out there in a way
you don't even want to be maybe put out
there yeah like it's still your stuff
they're cutting up yeah but it's just
kind of interesting it's like
they can kind of shape whatever you know
and then
people can see you more maybe than you
wanted to be seen I don't know yeah and
you give people a lot of yourself you
know it's interesting you have to though
I feel like the comedian land's a bit
different and I remember when I first
came out to LA like I went on your
podcast and I went on some other
comedians podcast and I was like damn
your guy's job is hard shout out to you
guys I don't know how you come up with
all this [ __ ] all the time really you
just you just have to have this like
verbose Gift of Gab to just spice up
because I'm sure like for example you
probably have told a lot of the same
stories oh yeah and but you have to come
with that sort of original energy
it was like when you ask me about like
the hitchhiking story like I would have
told it like funnier if I had nothing 20
times yeah but I feel like you guys have
to have this almost like a respawning
ability that is just like superhuman
yeah I think it be doing it with people
helps more yeah you know that's why even
like right when you walked in I really
felt like I lit up on the inside because
I was like oh man I get to talk with
someone today right and so that's it is
more it's nicer sometimes than just
talking about myself
um you know I find a lot of people like
will send in calls to podcasts like
there's a lot of guys out there
struggling these days yeah a lot of
people are are trying to figure out what
you know it's a weird time to be human
do you think that yeah definitely
what do you mean by that though I feel
like as we're switching more into like
uh putting more of our feelings and
everything in our
intentions and everything were so
reliant on media yeah and and uh just
human interaction has kind of taking a
back seat yeah um but it's also hasn't
so it's this weird
like
this weird thing because we're almost
more interactive than ever yeah but it's
not very real
it is but it's like we're almost
transitioning yeah it's it's it kind of
sucks that's why I've tapped out from it
I'm trying to reverse engineer in my own
life like I've like because I had to use
Instagram in these platforms I'm sure
you did too to get to where I am now
yeah but I've crossed this threshold
where it's like I don't need it anymore
you know what I mean like like you you
probably do either too I mean people are
going to watch your podcast and they're
going to watch your specials regardless
of if you have to post stories or
whatever I mean I'm sure it helps but
it's like once you're past that point
I'm not gonna hate on social media or
anything like that's yeah it's weird if
you got me to where I'm at you know but
like I'm gonna tap out from it like
because my human interactions have been
low especially in the past two years
yeah like dude it's like
my real friends like I don't know I need
more real real friends not just like
cool online friends but like real homies
yeah not a female and it gets addictive
though too that's another thing about it
like I almost wonder why did they let us
have phones because they're so addictive
it's like is it safe it's almost like a
cigarette it's like yeah at a certain
point where we realize this is this has
ruined us totally and Instagram is
low-key like kind of pornographic too
you know what I mean like a social like
a like a adrenaline porn or something no
like it literally is oh yeah I see them
tits on there or something no like like
a lot of my friends like I look at their
feeds and it's just like attractive
women attractive men just like
constantly and I'm like damn that must
be kind of weird for you and that's all
you're influences like you're like going
on your phone and just like scrolling
through like people you think are like
super bomb all the time like oh yeah
kind of rots your brain a little bit
like you know you're going through your
day and you're like you bet they look
amazing they look amazing yeah amazing
oh that's the homie I'm missing out I'm
missing out this person looks good I'm
like dude that that sucks yeah cause the
second you go back to your regular world
when you take that away from your eyes
and you look at your regular World your
regular world doesn't stand a chance
right really and it's designed like that
right you know right that's the part I
think people don't realize man we don't
realize that there are these
shape-shifting goons Jews you know what
I'm talking about
uh in the distance who are you know but
but that's uh we don't realize that a
lot of that has been
I you know it's it's been I mean they
have got us down to an algorithm Jordan
Peterson talks about that it's like we
can't the algorithm is so strong if you
want to still own yourself you have to
almost come to you have to come to your
own rescue man yeah you do and an
algorithm for everything and people only
realize when they're in it like even
Jordan Pearson talking about that he's
also got an algorithm oh yeah you know
what I mean and once you if you watch
one Jordan Peterson video You're Gonna
they're gonna you're gonna see him every
day and the same goes for uh Warren
Peterson cookbook yeah lobster for an
experiment you know the mob boss Michael
Francis easy yes I watched one Vlad TV
interview with Michael Francis and I'm
like let me watch four of these dude my
phone was like a mafia phone for like a
week every time I went there it's like
send me the bull describes his first hit
you know what I mean and it's just like
best soprano scenes you know Goodfellas
intro and I'm dude I'm watching this
[ __ ] all day you know I'm like La Costa
Nostra over here on my phone for a
[ __ ] week and you know I start
talking like these dudes
no I start talking to my homie he's
about the mafia my guy Evan's like dude
stop talking about the mop I'm like what
you know I'm like no but it's crazy the
Code of Silence is crazy dude blood and
blood out you know but not all Sicilians
are bad you know Evan's like stop saying
this [ __ ] let's talk about something
else and I'm like I realized you know
all moments of privacy which should have
been me time to think about my life I
was thinking about La Costa Nostra wow
and that's not right no one should think
about the mob for more than like an hour
a week oh yeah I think and even that
seemed like a lot you know especially if
it's not a recipe coming really shortly
after the thoughts yeah you think the
mob is still around if they are first of
all I noticed I noticed for a fact they
do a lot of just trash hauling is what
they do now yeah the mob has severely
been reduced you don't think they're
walking into like Stumptown Coffee in
Brooklyn breaking kneecaps like give me
five cents off this latte I think
they're like The Comedy Central
basically they're like Comedy Central
like they just [ __ ] didn't get on
social media and they [ __ ] fell apart
yeah they should have adapted oh I had
like a dope ass like cartel style
branding campaign yeah instead they
started like a Jordan Clepper show or
something and it [ __ ] tanked and they
never got their feedback under them
um let's bring them back dude yeah I
mean I I don't know but the mafia I
would love to see him back yeah I would
love a [ __ ] Italian to just beat and
hit me with a bat when I'm going for a
job oh yeah
because here's one thing I realized if
somebody walked up to me and punched me
for no reason right but they said you
know what that's for
I would find some I would find a reason
in my head why yeah and I'm like damn
okay
I think you could do that to anybody
what do you think would be the first
thing that would come to mind
um
probably
stealing something when I was younger
maybe yeah or you know you know bad sex
maybe yeah they get me drive all the way
over there for that bad sex or my you
know you made my sister come over for
that bad sex yeah
you were heavy into stealing when you
were younger yeah I like to have stuff
man and I tell people I'd have their
stuff on and tell them I didn't have it
you know like retail yeah and even
undergarments men's undergarments yeah
you've came a long way man yeah thanks
man I you know I feel yeah at least now
I can afford my own stuff hands would
probably send you a pack
they're gonna see this shout out to
Haynes um I want to know about your
movie before you go man I want to know a
little bit more about it yeah man ask
away uh what can we look forward to
obviously there's some parts of it that
are what
there's parts of the movie that I'm
going to be screening at the upcoming
tour okay that's a fact I'm gonna scream
like some sick at the HBO just finally
agreed to let me show some scenes okay
HBO's been awesome to work with really
yeah dude wow sick shout out to Nina at
HBO it's been fun dude like working with
the company that's like keeps it real
and you know it's HBO and especially you
came you had some bat you had bad
experiences with that before right hell
yeah dude I remember you were in
right after I met you through uh with
king and the sting you that's when you
got into the dispute with your own
organization yeah yeah that was a
horrible thing yeah but you know I'm
happy that uh it ended in like a
cataclysmic [ __ ] gnarly way because I
had to go independent like I had to
start channel five right because I had
like the fire under my ass being like
you know you got [ __ ] over like
respawn kill it like start your own
thing that thing's gonna be bigger you
know I feel like if I didn't have that
dramatic split from the August no breaks
parent company I'd probably would have
just drifted into like comedic obscurity
honestly what do you what was a moment
in there what was some more of that tell
me about that so because other people
this happened this happens to people a
lot where people you know their con the
deal isn't right or they don't feel like
if they leave something that they're
still going to be able to survive yeah
there's just very like low regulation of
like the Instagram and Tick Tock
management uh world it's not like
filming you know acting and [ __ ] where
you have guilds and unions like you can
get pimped you can get the blood pimped
out of You by someone to manage as
influencers there's no rules or
regulations it's like the wild west I
there's been contracts much worse than
mine but I had what they call a 360 deal
they talk about it a lot in rap music
you know it's a full management contract
so that means I can't acquire any money
or get any if I get a sponsorship deal
it runs through the parent company I
every stream of Revenue that it's to
Andrew Callahan will have to be
processed by the parent company and
they'll give me 20 of that profit after
expenses are recouped so it's a shitty
deal yeah uh it was good at first
because they gave me 45k a year bought
me an RV I thought I was in heaven but
there was no show yet right as the show
got bigger and bigger you know we're
getting I see that we're making like so
much on patreon every month and through
merch yeah and I'm like I want more
money than I'm getting right now I'm
getting yeah I deserve more I'm getting
paid literally the salary of a manager
raising canes and like shout out to them
and I'm like you know like they work
hard they're not even a sponsor
sorry go on and then like
man
yeah so that happened it happens to
people but it ended up making you didn't
fold though yeah I mean so back to it I
mean the big lesson from that whole [ __ ]
is like read your contracts and uh know
what real money looks like you know
because before you start you know really
succeeding in media 45k a year seems
like a great deal
but then in the world of adults that's
like a below standard salary right but
you just don't know that because you're
young as [ __ ] but you were 21. I was
just interning for Seattle weekly and
running for my college newspaper for
free so it's like anyways
somewhere right right before Augusto
breaks kind of tagged uh we signed a
deal to make a movie with Tim and Eric's
company absolutely and then Jonah Hill's
company strong baby lashed on to it and
it became this whole like a lot of chefs
in the kitchen making this uh the movie
is about the 2020 election and uh the
events that led up to the capital Riot
and the aftermath so we're making this
movie I don't remember I'm in the South
Philly Walmart in this RV we're out of
propane so there's no heat it's 21
degrees and I'm getting these emails
from the August no breaks parent company
that are like we need you to produce two
pieces of patreon content or we're gonna
fire you guys
and this is while I'm making a movie and
I'm like I don't have time to do that
I'm I'm freezing it was horrible and so
I kind of refused you know I asked for
more money I said okay I'll work a
second job now just give me more than 20
of the profit share they're like nah
we're keeping you at 20 they fired Nick
and Evan just to make a statement after
I asked them for more bread and those
are your Associates yeah still they
they're partners and owners of channel
five right and then like yeah dude it
just got so bad they were just being
like and they got this thing in the mail
my La house it was like if you don't
make a video for orgasm Breaks by the
end of the month
you're fired in the mail what are they
are they
where they send it from the past do they
travel back in time
what's going on but looking back on it I
mean I'm like I said I'm glad it fell
apart I don't have really negative
feelings towards any of those guys yeah
you know I was I was always supposed to
be independent yeah you know you always
have been probably really in your own
way yeah for sure you like being
it seems like you like having control
over what you put out yeah in a way I
almost feel bad for those guys because
they made such a bad business decision
right well at first they made a great
business because they saw the value in
you yeah so that's almost this that's
cool yeah but then they chose to not do
it fairly yeah because I would have kept
working for Augusta breaks like the show
would have been going right now if they
would have just been like Andrew wants
more money
sure give it to him but I remember the
dude said to me we have a bunch of
Connections in the comedy World we'll be
fine we're gonna replace you hmm and I
was like bro I do the editing it's my
show it's like my concept they actually
created a bunch of CopyCat pages that
are active right now with my exact Style
with other comedians hosting it it's
just a shameful Endeavor but you know
I don't know sometimes you take L's and
you just got to keep it pushing but I
think they should have just left my
formula alone
yeah dude I mean if you put a bunch of
L's together bruh
you got a bunch of L's but you how can
you might be doing better yeah but hey
man shout out to those guys like they
put me on it first you know it's a good
attitude to have man I try not to have
any I just try to like not be negative
about [ __ ] you know even though it's
easy to be especially when you like got
kind of burned like that yeah but once
you
once you start being negative people
start being negative back I know it's
basic but like even with my old block
video you know like I had
like
I showed two other like journalists in
that maybe not in like the best light
you know because I was doing like a sort
of expose about like what I saw as like
the exploitation of like drill music by
like media members who run like an
interview cycle based upon like fact
checking someone's Street Credibility
okay for clicks and Views I talked about
that actually feels real life violence
because
it kind of breaks down the inner
workings of gang beef to like the
general listening public
and just makes people like not only fans
of the music but fans are like the
ganglore Behind the Music which you know
what I'm saying oh interesting no I know
what you're saying I just I'm trying to
imagine how a channel would do something
like that basically like um uh
drill music is like completely full of
like dissing people's dead family
members dissing dead enemies there's a
whole gang lore behind every drill scene
whether it be Jacksonville Philadelphia
Chicago with specific characters and
legends and people like that but the
general YouTube public didn't know about
what they were saying until like a
second industry of uh
you know people who I call gang gossip
YouTubers ran like a news circuit based
upon like breaking [ __ ] down ah you know
and like that sort of exposed the inner
workings of of like Chicago's gang
conflict to like the just greater
civilian public
stoke the Flames of it made it worse is
that helpful when they do that or no I
think that uh it's just click bait I
think that at its best like there's some
people who do it really well like this
one guy um trapped Laura Ross he does
like a really good job at like you know
breaking down sort of the insanity and
like the specifics of certain conflicts
that should people should know about you
know because there's people dying about
like the hundreds here like in
Jacksonville right but I think that when
it's a a gossip-based click cycle like
you'll never guess what gang this
rapper's from
you know that to me is whack right but
what I was saying is
in the whole block video I interviewed
two dudes who were in that world and I
just felt like while I do have my
problems with like how they use their
platform to a certain degree
it felt bad
coming at anyone I don't want to do it
again you know like just putting the and
putting any negativity in the world like
I felt it kind of come back towards me
when they had their responses and then
people were and I was just like right I
don't want to start any beef with any
other media members like [ __ ] all that
like you know yeah
yeah it's tough to navigate because
sometimes people will steal like we'll
borrow your [ __ ] or do something like
that too and you're like man this is
[ __ ] up it's like do I wanna you know
like it's like do I call this out like
there's a clothing company that like
totally copied a shirt that I made right
like a merch and it was like do I bring
this up or is that just gonna bring more
attention to them you know yeah it's
tough to navigate sometimes stuff like
that I know that's a different
comparison yeah
um but it's like once you start calling
people out for [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden you're susceptible because people
now that you've stooped that level of
like right internet beef people start
realizing it's an opportunity to
capitalize on you and they start
internet beefing with you because they
know that you play that game now right
and I just don't want to do it I stand
behind my coverage of oh block but it's
just like I don't know is it scary to
see like you know you get environments
like that where there's a lot of
violence you know a lot of like growing
up like two of my closest black friends
from growing up both got killed right
and um by other black guys growing up
there's just a lot of like VI you know
there's a there's a lot of black young
men killed you know there's a lot of
violence in that Community yeah you see
a lot of like the rap music and stuff
and you know I love I love the music but
is it I wonder sometimes I find like by
listening to his music am I just
perpetuating part of this thing well the
music is very much a part of the
circumstances and like a reflection of
the environment and the culture creates
it the real villain in the story of the
mainstream proliferation of drill music
is the record labels who are [ __ ]
pushing this [ __ ] and like owning the
Masters to mainstream hits about like
basically doing mass shootings you know
so as a listener man it sounds dope no
you're not perpetuating it the music
sounds tight they could be talking about
whatever right but it's the it's the
record labels that you know make kids
bop versions of songs
and [ __ ] like that you know to me I felt
like when I do something again if I ever
step back into the realm of covering
drill music I I feel like the record
labels and the people who control and
incentivize that or they're missing uh
sort of Investigation the missing piece
to my investigation investigative
reporting you know
do you feel like you're like you bow
your reporting down to anything like you
there's like there's angles you're
afraid to go to or things you won't talk
about like it's hard to stay
neutral
yeah I mean I'll talk about whatever but
there's certain issues that I take more
seriously than others it's hard to stay
out of the pocket of
big business too you know as you grow
yeah because they'll take your clips and
they'll run them if it is with their
agenda you know I mean or they could
start to make you look a certain way
like this guy does this or you know yeah
they have just a lot of power out there
especially when you start to succeed and
that's why I wanted to get off social
media because it's like I remember one
time I was like out in a nice restaurant
and like I had like I had got shots for
everybody and someone took a picture of
me and they were like I see where our
patreon Ray's going oh wow you know and
[ __ ] like that where I'm just like bro
like I just like let me enjoy my life to
a degree like I'm supporting my entire
family now basically you know what I
mean so it's like I don't know man
success is hella weird
because I never thought I'd be someone
who was successful and it comes with a
whole different responsibility and it's
harder to make real friends it's scary
kind of isn't it it's hella scary
especially when you're young you know
and you you've popped off when you're
young too yeah so you know what it's
like it's like damn
like I have less friends than ever you
know but the friends that I do have are
really strong yeah but like I can't be
around it and your own ego I got scared
of my own ego too because you know
feeling like I had I was at a loss you
know of like uh attention or affection
growing up and I was like oh this is
important you know like this specific
part of it you know that can be scary
yeah it's all interesting I think people
look for like uh examples of ego
exaggeration too to be like oh this
guy's super full of himself because he
did this yeah like once you succeed
people look for a villain Arc to be like
oh he used to be dope but you know now
he's at Soho house and he's going to
Equinox and paying for hot stone
massages and I just saw him with airpods
in yeah you know [ __ ] that guy with a
sellout you know and like that's a real
narrative especially you know I'm
someone who like cares about you know
issues of like racial Justice and [ __ ]
yeah so it's like that's not that
compatible with having money and my goal
is not to have money but it's like
when you succeed people kind of know
what you're doing you're doing well and
like every time I sell merch which is
like the money goes right back into
funding channel five but everyone's just
like have fun like grifting or whatever
I'm just like whatever people want to
support you people want to have your
stuff they want to be like oh I like
this this is something cool I used to
think about that we try to sell merch at
a fair price and we try to do the best
that we can and at a certain point you
can spend all day I can sit there and be
like a guy who's handling all my merch
stuff or merch issues but then I'm not
even creating anything that people want
or even honoring Myself by being CR it's
like there's only so many wars you can
fight you know dude for sure and that's
why I'm just like chilling on the
chilling on the Instagram yeah good for
you man it's Brave and it's hard to do
yeah it's like vaping for your [ __ ]
uh ego yeah I'm one month off wow crazy
damn that's powerful dude I didn't know
that um yeah I'm not gonna believe I'm
not I'm not gonna make any public
statement being like screen time is bad
for you the coolest thing to do is just
with withdraw on your own time because
the only thing labor than being addicted
to Instagram is being one of those
people who's like publicly against
Instagram yeah on Instagram yeah yeah on
Instagram being like I'm taking a break
from my mental recovery it's like oh are
you yeah thanks for letting us know dude
this isn't part of your long-term uh
Instagram plan is it taking a break from
my break then they'll come back and take
a break from the break oh that was so
refreshing great to see you guys again
how's it going it's been four days yeah
for sure um what about the love life man
do you do you envision yourself are you
dating is there anything like that for
you do you like uh like affection yeah
for sure it's just hard to navigate in
this the position that I'm in you know
yeah like I'm like hyper um
not hyper critical but like I definitely
trust problems yeah because of like the
position that I'm in I feel like I'm
really paranoid about you know if
someone's like genuine or not
interesting and so that makes me like
not open up to people because I'm like
damn this sounds like a classic thing
but it's like would you be around
if I don't have all this [ __ ] going on
if I wasn't like yeah doing cool stuff
and that extends like Beyond dating
that's just like all of social life but
I'm taking it slow like I have a lot on
my plate like I have this movie coming
out I have the tour working on a cartoon
I definitely have put the whole love
life thing in the back seat yeah until
I'm like satisfied with other stuff you
know because Love Can Crash environment
if you make awesome stuff that's forever
you know if you put your passion into a
project that's going to outlive you when
also I noticed my passion my work can't
hurt me like at a level you know like my
work can't
my work is always I know exactly what
it's going to be I know the return is
going to give me
it can't affect me you know it can but
it's not going to have the same effect
as as a loving somebody or something
like that you know yeah anyway that's
kind of a [ __ ] big reach but it's not
going to go on your phone while you're
sleeping yeah yes yeah my job's not
going to go on my phone honestly yeah
yeah that's true also it's like I feel
like if you do date people in this
position like they assume that you're
like hella Unfaithful when you're not oh
interesting you know what I mean like
yeah I think that's probably true a lot
of times if I meet a girl the first
thing you ever say is I bet you know
girls all over right and I can spend
like two days with someone like have the
best time yeah and they're like I'm just
one of many I'm like no no that's not
even true yeah like you have the best
like have like a honeymoon basically
yeah the last thing they say is like all
right I'll see you in a month never I'm
like man
yeah they do but I guess that's an
accurate thing for somebody if you're
just kind of also we pass through town
guys like us pass through town you know
yeah and we're tit grifters you know and
that is something and some of that's
first of all okay we've also created
this Ambiance in the world like it's not
like I get a lot of gems from women like
let's [ __ ] let me see that penis hole no
oh I swear okay dude the stuff I gotten
let me see that dick hole or whatever
you know just crazy
I I like what I didn't even so it's like
there's women out there trying to get
you to stop by as well yeah and there's
nothing inhuman about it I've seen I've
been at the zoo before animal walk
across the cage [ __ ] another animal I
don't even know them yeah or her they'd
even look yeah and then they go back
dude they go back to whatever the dog
food or whatever they give them a little
dog food you notice that at the zoo I
didn't know that man it's like yeah
every like everything eats dog food yeah
I try to avoid like um doing that type
of thing though like for tour like when
I'm on tour I just like to work finish
the show do the meet and greet and just
keep it pushing yeah I gotta watch the
ego too you know and there's no like
worse way there's no worse thing for
your ego than like being surrounded by
surrounding yourself with like fans or
people in your DMs
like saying [ __ ] like that yeah you know
because you just develop a complex where
I I haven't developed it but my biggest
fear is thinking that I'm better than
other people or that I have more value
than just random garbage man or
something well and also in your ego can
grow without you even knowing it that's
what's even scary yeah the ego like a
damn Moss bro yeah that thing it grows
at night yeah also the weirdest [ __ ] is
like in the regular world people are
attracted to like
being like athletic I'm like funny
whereas if like in the media world or in
like the LA world it's like who you know
and stuff yeah
yeah it's different man it's interesting
well you're certainly on a journey bro
and I appreciate you coming in and just
kind of spending some time with us and
just you know getting to know you better
man and and learn about kind of some of
the stuff that's made you tick and yeah
dude damn yeah the sky's the limit dude
um
one last question do you think about
like uh you're do you think that there's
still good journalism out there oh so
much man
that's one comment that I get on my
videos that I don't like is people
always say the last journalist or
something like that like no man I'm
heavily inspired by Louis Thoreau by
Daily Show correspondents by like Sasha
Baron Cohen people I'm you know Vice
when I was in high school was the [ __ ]
yeah if I was so far when it first came
out yeah I got bought the old school
days when it was like like the
interviews with General butt naked in
Liberia yeah so you're like oh my God
like I want to be doing stuff like this
I only hope that I can create and
Inspire like more journalists more
civilian independent journalists to go
out there and get like the real take but
I feel like I watch interviews that are
dope all the time
I watch interviews all day on YouTube
and I'm just loling dang that's cool but
the hard part is like you know inter
there's too many interviews now yeah do
you feel that way yeah yeah whereas
we're doing an interview we're saying it
yeah like I'm saying stick this too much
oh yeah yeah I TR I try less and less I
realize more I just want to have a chat
yeah there's just too many like on
YouTube like maybe it's an algorithm
thing but it's like it's definitely an
algorithm thing but nah man I mean I I
want to do this forever yeah and I'm not
mad at anyone
yeah I'm curious bro I'm curious to see
where
yeah I'm curious to see where you where
you take it man you're so creative and
it's fun it's fun to listen to and it's
fun to learn and and see what you're
doing man I appreciate your time Andrew
yeah dude it's been sick being on I like
the it's just you and me you know what I
mean yeah I see why you like a more
one-on-one podcast Style
yeah it makes me feel more comfortable I
can be myself I can try to learn more
about the person yeah
and yeah I don't know sometimes you go
through times in your life where you
feel like I need to evolve and I don't
know how to do that right now and so I
need to take a step back and see what do
I do yeah I wanted to ask you who's like
your dream uh podcast guest
um we had a little Boosie on I would
like to have him again so good dude yeah
I like Lucy man because he's so
he's so real and on
uncut but also trying to figure [ __ ] out
you know you guys are just pure
Louisiana too bro yeah I love Boosie who
else dude there's a Senator John Kennedy
I think his name is from Louisiana no
what's his name
uh from Louisiana John Bel Edwards no
that guy that would be a terrible yeah
I think that's the Governor John Neely
candidate yeah there's this other dude
from Louisiana I want to get that dude
from Louisiana that does those crazy
videos if you're a criminal up in our
town oh I didn't know I thought it was
Florida that's Louisiana it's got to be
Shreveport or some [ __ ] yeah this dude
says some wild she just like has great
sound bites I would love to sit and chat
with him that guy hates crime you can
look at him and just tell all types of
crime dude you park in the yellow he's
on your ass oh that's true he does that
he [ __ ] has the most he has that
whole monitor Vibe he does I can
literally picture a young him who else
is somebody I would love to really
interview man
um
man JJ Watt I think would be real
interesting
um oh I wanted to interview mystical so
bad and he just got arrested again for
the same type of [ __ ] I know really
damn he just can't stop being a [ __ ]
bad man it that bro that broke my heart
because I was so I kept reaching out to
him I even dm'd him a couple times we've
been messaging and uh
and and he did then he got then he got
busted so if he ever gets hot I would
like to I would love to get to chat with
him how about NBA young boy would you do
that yeah be Fire It's A Hard One to get
I've been trying to get it for a long
time have you yeah he's hard yeah I was
curious as to how you go about your
guest do you use publicist and reach out
to use just different Avenues personally
check in with people yeah yeah
Trey young I think it would be real cool
I'd like to get him from Atlanta Hawks
yeah that would be good he just seemed
like an interesting guy I gotta rewatch
your interview with Boosie man that's
was one of my favorite my favorite
podcast you've ever done it was fun man
we had to give we had to give him a huge
bag of weed and like uh a couple Grand
you know to show up that's not too bad
how much you need a couple ounces of
weed it was a no it was like this much
weed we could pound of weed yeah yeah it
was It was a
[Laughter]
and the best was afterwards here we go
outside
he was dancing in the parking lot and he
opens up this SUV
two of these like red bone chicks get
out of there dude and uh
like one of his hair was like stuck in
the seatbelt thing but they've all been
there just smoking and partying have you
seen how he asks his fans for random
[ __ ] on the road he's like who in
Atlanta has a Pontiac GT he's like I
need a Pontiac GT rental car with Note
with good tags and he's like email my
manager and like the next thing you know
it's some family like what up Boosie and
he's like appreciate it man oh you
should look up when you get home Boosie
asking fans for things on Instagram it's
like a 20 minute compilation I love that
man what are some groups you want to get
into man are there some outlier groups
you don't even know exist yet I'm sure
uh the adult baby Community oh really or
they call it the age play Community
people who pretend to be babies you know
get caretakers to read their bedtime
stories some go as far as
getting their diaper changed and such
wow
I could see that man it's important
yeah that's a good one I interviewed an
adult baby at Folsom Street Fair in San
Francisco two weeks ago super cool dude
hmm you'll see it yeah he was just like
I had a terrible childhood didn't get to
experience being a kid
and I just walks around in a diaper with
a binky damn that's pretty gangster
yeah there's some definitely unique
groups out there man I'm curious because
a lot of them we learn through you man
for real you know like my favorite part
on those jizz wizard dudes was when they
had the one dude that busted out like a
real
you know he had that Rorschach test and
the other dude just had that little jizz
on the paper you're talking about the
different coloration between will and
Brian Seaman on the paper yeah yeah
Brian's was extremely dark yeah like
orange
like the minute Maidstone is disgusting
well I mean I want to say disgusting
Brian if you're watching this it was
more Halloween I don't think your
ejaculate is disgusting however I would
suggest you consult your primary care
physician as to why it's so discolored
it's pumpkin spice everything's pumpkin
like it's just that time of year too you
like how weird oh yeah what are you
gonna be I don't know I might do
something else it's your farmer or
something yeah you know take it pretty
easy what you got Michael Myers I'm just
gonna minion it really yeah just like
paint my whole body yellow on one of the
goggles and speak that whatever like
hybrid of uh Spanish and Italian yeah
minions good man that's a great idea
actually yeah shout out to the minions
honestly that movie was fire as hell
it's uh that whole series is so great
man I went and saw Zach Bryan the other
night have you ever seen him no is he
involved in minions no he's just a
musician but it was awesome oh hell yeah
yeah it just reminded me how great it is
to go see live music
live anything this makes you feel you
know you're like oh this is and it
reminds your brain that you can do
different things you know sometimes you
don't get enough real input you know
yeah yeah it's like you don't get enough
actual performance and they only you
know praise you for the one thing they
know you're good at but you feel you're
so funny
right but then you know you're an
amazing athlete and you're great at
[ __ ] listening to music but then my
brain forgets those other things so if I
got to go out and have real experiences
yeah you know people always ask say to
me which is hella weird huh they go how
do you find all these crazy ass people
and I'm like everyone is insane yeah you
know what I mean like
yeah bro I'm like dude are you what's
the last time you talked to a person you
know people we got problems everyone's
got serious stuff going on you know
we're like in the we're like in The
Matrix we're out here we are man
freaking out here I'm happy to spend
time with you in the Matrix today Andrew
Callahan man best of luck on the tour
we'll put it in the link and everything
like that oh for real yeah dude this is
gonna be tight so cool I appreciate it
you weren't feeling well I appreciate
you making the time yeah man yeah hell
yeah hope to see everyone on tour man
yeah man I will come out when you're in
Nashville I'll come here for real yeah
National or L.A so
we'll do it I'll be so sick thanks guys
[Music]